foreign
thank you
back
similarly I I go for the music and the
company the social aspect of it
particularly the people because we have
such a love and we're such a friendly
crowd
when I came originally because
um I need to keep fit and I was getting
a bit bored with my sewing machine and
my card making so I thought well I'll go
out and do something else and I like
dance I've always loved dancing and
I can't enjoyed coming yeah yeah as far
as I'm concerned it's you know Wednesday
is the day that I'm reported
so there's the music that is a really
nice kind of element to it what else
um kind of keeps you coming back why do
you come kind of every week so there's
the music
evening
full apart
foreign